so explain what do you think is going on
right now there was a technical issue of
New York Stock Exchange and also nicely
market their smallest exchange they had
to halt trading on those exchanges at
eleven-thirty to this morning 1132 they
were having problems before the open but
they fixed them in time for the open and
then they said everything is okay just
after eleven they had more technical
issues again and then they halted
trading 1132 but there are 11 public
exchanges in the market and Julie was
saying there's all sorts of other venues
these two exchanges right now on trading
so but we don't see and I want to just
continue to point this out because a lot
of times you have sort of alarmist or a
sensationalist people in the media that
freak out around these issues and it's a
huge deal obviously we've got a big red
headline but you do not see a market
collapse and it continues to amaze me
that we still see the dow only down 200
points and it is still trading in a lot
of other venues so even though the New
York Stock Exchange is closed for now 40
minutes you still see actual you still
see action and you still see relative
safety in markets here yeah this this is
one of the benefits of a fragmented
market that also draws a lot of
criticisms is when during the day
something one exchange goes down we
actually had another exchange on Monday
one of the bats exchanges went down and
it didn't have any trading and no one
barely even noticed that one the issue
could come for the closing auction as
New York Stock Exchange's where New York
Stock Exchange listed stocks typically
clothes as a big closing auction is a
lot of volume there a lot of funds use
the closing price to set you know there
na vi's for the day but we're still
several hours from that and I nicely
working very hard taxes I wonder well to
your last point nice he's working very
hard to fix it when I spot the new york
stock exchange I noticed they fired a
heck of a lot of people who had decades
of experience working with issues like
this and who had basically grown up down
in that building do you think they may
be cut costs too much because it doesn't
seem like they're fixing it very quickly
nor are they disseminating a lot of
information you--you'll from front well
I often find in situations like this the
exchanges can be quite hard to get
information from the ice folks have
actually they actually bought
a technology company and they're going
to be upgrading all of New York Stock
Exchange's systems later this year from
what I hear just you know on background
I think they're acutely aware the nicest
technology perhaps isn't you know best
in the industry and they definitely
working to upgrade it as to what exactly
happened today we don't know yet